good morning kellyanne good morning what
is your reaction to what happened
yesterday
i'd like to add my voice to the ongoing
chorus of those thanking the secret
service they are incredible men and
women
and they did their job here you saw the
president resumed his duties that's very
donald trump also
the show must go on the briefing went on
and i will say though
that the violence that's erupting all
over the country in our great cities
is is really the bigger story here just
look at chicago beautiful american city
you know they've had uh 414 people
murdered this year
over a roughly 50 increase over last
year 1900 people shot
including these kids ladies and
gentlemen just stop and think about the
nine children
who have been murdered in chicago this
year through gunshots a little boy
three years old in the back of his
parents car
just riding along a 13 year old in her
house in front of her entire
in front of her entire family and then
just overnight you have
allegedly the seattle police chief
carmen best who's been on your network
many times
after serving 28 years in becoming the
police chief there african-american
woman
is resigning because the council is
making good on its promise to cut the
budget there for law enforcement
it would have reduced over 100 officers
you know this is
in the shadow of the gallup poll last
week that showed
86 percent of americans want the same
or more police presence in their
communities and that includes 83 percent
of hispanic americans and 81
of african americans and what's really
regrettable
is that i see these mayors in their
press conferences
and really shameless uh but not
blameless and not nameless
what what is the most common word they
say in their press conferences
not police not sympathy trump
trump trump trump we will not have the
president and the feds here
you know everybody is uh flexing their
social media muscle they're all so tough
and and it just it means that people are
shoveling hate at police officers
shoveling hate
people who work here i think that people
are also worried that donald trump's
going to get four more years
and they're starting to lose it and you
see that
here and elsewhere yesterday as well you
all you do see a lot of trump
derangement syndrome and we've been
talking about that for a while kellyanne
of course that shooting occurred just as
the president was
starting his uh coronavirus briefing
in the briefing room the big which is
great because he updates us on what is
happening in the united states
there's international news this morning
and that is
russia claims that they have now
developed a covid19 vaccine and they're
going to start vaccinating millions of
teachers
and front line health care workers this
month
but you know behind that headline i was
reading that the testing has been really
small and some people are saying and we
don't know if this is safe
apparently they've given it to some of
the scientists who worked on it
and 50 military members and some
volunteers
but that is not the large testing group
that we are used to seeing
that's right that's why the u.s
standards are so much more stringent
we of course our fda in our country
sets the standards and what i understand
from the russia announcement is
this is nowhere near where we are which
is we have six different vaccine
candidates
into phase three and they don't seem to
be there yet and even dr anthony fauci
earlier this month testified
under oath in front of congress and said
he hopes that when china and russia
are releasing their vaccines more
widespread that they've gone through
rigorous testing
at the very least he said it would be
problematic if that were not true
the president is getting a vaccine
update here at the white house today
i'm sure he will announce that in an
open press event and also
probably in his press briefing later on
today and uh what he will be talking
about are these six candidates
including operation warp speed
which has just been an incredible
success to date
we even now nih director dr
collins said recently he's been there
for decades and has never seen something
come together
so swiftly and so successfully the
result to americans what they need to
know is that we are in the final phases
with a couple of those six candidate
vaccine candidates and we think we can
have hundreds of millions of doses in
the next few months alone and we can't
wait for that update so let's talk about
it let's talk about the risk
johnson and johnson yeah kellyanne can
we just talk uh
real quick in the minute we have left a
minute or so we have left is
what's going on with their rescue
package the washington post reports
today that white house officials that
might be you
uh believe that president trump has
gained leverage with his executive
actions does that mean
that democrats have to reach out to the
white house in order to resume
talks or might the white house and
leadership reach out to democrats
it can go either way but we've never
stopped talking uh the president said
yesterday they have his phone number
they know where he lives and works
also we have our chief negotiators still
very much in the game involved in the
game
and i think what the president did this
weekend showed america two big things
number one is
in the absence of congressional
leadership and action this president
will always step into the breach
and number two what the president did is
he basically told america
when you look at your monthly bills i'm
trying to help you
stay in your homes or your apartments
through the non-eviction notices
the non-eviction relief also get a
couple extra
get some more money for the 400 plus on
top of whatever you're already receiving
so it can help you with food or
medicines or meet other household
expenses
and also the president gave relief for
the rest of 2020 ladies and gentlemen
for student loan payments that
forbearance will help so many people are
staring at different bills every month
and saying
i can't meet my basic expenses i can't
sleep at night he's given relief on his
own you know what the democrats did and
they're friends of the media
yet i repeat myself they they attacked
it
oh this can't be and you didn't do well
congress
step up step in i noticed a number of
those uh elite
leaders quote unquote very generous of
me in congress are speaking at the
democratic convention maybe chuck
schumer can
use his convention speech next week to
announce that he's
he's he has a relief package with the
republicans with the white house that
would be a much better use of his time
than whatever invested they're going to
hurl the president but let's get this
done for the american people the
president is ready to sign it
all right kellyanne thanks so much thank
you